From drug trials to brain research, mice are
critical to scientific studies.
Some labs are just lousy with mice.
You know what science needs though?
More mice.
Hi everyone, Julian here for DNews.
The power of science derives from testing
an idea over and over.
Obviously that raises ethical problems when
something needs to be tested on humans.
You can’t just create a new drug and then
immediately start trying it on people, who
knows what the side effects might be?
That’s why between test tube experiments
and human trials, a new drug has to pass the
gatekeeper that is Mus musculus, the humble
lab mouse.
Mice have been crucial to advancing science.
They’ve contributed so much to so many fields
that there’s even a statue dedicated to
them outside the Institute of Cytology and
Genetics in Novosibirsk, Russia.
Animal rights groups may not like it, but
the mice’s sacrifices have saved many a
human life.
Still, there’s a bit of a problem.
For years, decades even, studies have mostly
been using male mice.
When studies report what sex mice they used,
males outnumber females five fold.
And in a survey of 1,200 papers, only 42%
of them bothered reporting what sex their
lab animals were at all, meaning that gap
could be much greater.
According to a Scientific American article
by Brook Borel, the thinking was that male
mice didn’t have that pesky hormone cycle
female mice have, so their results would be
more consistent.
Once the male mice gave you a result, you
could just extrapolate to females and start
testing with humans.
Well not to sound like a hackneyed comedian,
but have you ever noticed that men and women
are different?
Our brains and bodies do not function identically
so if a drug is going to be used for both
sexes, it’s probably a good idea to know
how that drug will affect each sex.
The drug example Borel gives is Ambien.
As it turns out, many women metabolize the
sleep aid much slower than men, to the point
that they’re still too impaired to drive
the next day.
It took 21 years for the FDA to half the recommended
dose for women.
Oh incidentally the U.S. National Institute
of Health (NIH) mandated the inclusion of
women and minorities in clinical trials receiving
their grant money in 1993, a year after Ambien
was approved by the FDA,
So for over two decades women have been represented
in human trials, but female mice have been
getting snubbed.
The problem with excluding female mice is
researchers might miss something important.
Women have adverse reactions to prescription
drugs more often than men do, even with a
drug as innocuous as aspirin.
A low-dose has long been recommended to help
prevent heart attacks.
But according to a study published in the
journal Heart in 2014, healthy women under
65 are more likely to suffer from intestinal
bleeding from regular use.
Since women are 1.5 to 1.7 times more likely
to have an adverse drug reaction, it makes
sense to have analogues that might catch that
early.
And they may benefit from certain drugs more
too.
One experiment looking into using oxytocin
as an autism treatment used males and females
of a strain that had problems socializing.
The female mice started socializing more quickly
than the males, suggesting oxytocin might
be a more effective treatment for women than
for men.
Sex differences can also help point researchers
in a new direction.
For example, women are more susceptible to
multiple-sclerosis (MS), but the disease is
usually less severe.
By studying male and female mice that suffer
from a similar condition called rodent experimental
autoimmune encephalomyelitis, it’s been
discovered that some genes on the Y chromosome
may have a protective effect, while some genes
on the X chromosome may cause the disease.
With the benefits in mind, a year ago the
NIH mandated that all research grant proposals
submitted would either have to use both sexes
or justify why they used only one.
It’s a pretty big deal considering the NIH
funds over 300,000 researchers.
But are those initial worries that a hormone
cycle and behavioral differences would corrupt
data justified?
Jill Silverman of University of California,
Davis, has been using male and female mice
in her autism research for years.
When comparing how mice from six different
strains performed on various behavioral tests,
there was no significant difference between
the sexes.
That’s not to say they don’t exist, but
it’s more dependent on how the test is designed
and what the researchers are looking for.
Really the biggest issue is cost.
The number of mice used would need to double
in some experiments, and they would have to
be separated to make sure they don’t breed.
Silverman says she needs to use at least 20
mice in each test group to make her findings
statistically significant, which usually means
at least 60 mice per experiment.
If that number doubles for other studies,
taking care of twice as many mice over the
course of months can inflate costs dramatically.
Still, the benefits of finding out how something
affects both sexes, or discovering a new path
for research to go down is probably going
to be worth it in the long run.
During this whole thing you were probably
wondering, why do we even use mice???
Well Trace has that covered right here.
I’m all for more females in STEM, even if
they’re fuzzy and tiny and white.
Are you a woman in the STEM fields?
What do you do, and what’s your take on
mandatory female mice?
And even if you’re not, we want to hear
your opinion anyway.
Let us know in the comments.
Subscribe for more, and I’ll see you next
time on DNews